ومن مهد التظاهرات سقف مسقط راس الشابه
مهسا اميني لا يكل ولا يمل الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي من العباره الاكثر
ترديدا خلال فتره الاحتجاجات قائلا انها
مدبره من الاعداء وان الغرب خاصه امريكا
التي تشن تيارا معاديا ضدنا هي التي تتولى
ذلك مضيفا ان ان البلاد هو الخط الاحمر
والقضيه المحوريه لكل مجتمع ودوله ولن
يسمح لاحد بان يمس ايران مشددا ايضا على
انها هنا مع مرتكبي الجرائم اضافه الى
ضروره تقديمهم للعداله حاول هذه المره ان
يشهد عاطفه المدنيين من محافظه كردستان
غرب البلاد مع تاكيده ان العدو لا يعلم من
يواجه بل انه يجهل ان كردستان ضحت بدمائي
سكانها مستذكرا انه منتصره في حروبهم في
الماضي ويقصد الحرب الايرانيه العراقيه
قبل نحو نصف
في مقال مطول لصحيفه واشنطن بوست ستاند
الى شهاده 15 مسؤولا في واشنطن واوروبا
وشرق الاوسط اكدوا ان النظام يصعد من
جهوده لملاحقه المعارضين في الخارج كما في
الداخل حيث اوضح المسؤولون ان اجهزه
المخابرات والامن الايرانيه تعتمد الى حد
كبير على الوكلاء لتنفيذ خططهم وتقدم مئات
الالاف من الدولارات لللصوص للمجوهرات
وتجار المخدرات وغيرهم من المجرمين لتنفيذ
مخططات القتل وملاحقه المعارضين
ووفقا الصحيفه افشت بل افشلت عده وكالات
امنيه حول العالم محاولات اغتيال قام بها
ايرانيون مثلا كمحاولات قتل المستشار
الامن القومي السابق في امريكا جون بولتن
في واشنطن وواحده وواحده الاختطاف الصحفيه
الايرانيه الامريكيه مسيحه لنجاه في مدينه
نيويورك عدا عن محاولات بالفشل لقتل
مواطنين بريطانيا اض الى احباط عمليه
باستخدام تاجر مخدرات ايراني لقتل الصحفي
الفرنسي برنارد هاندري ليفي في العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس
[موسيقى]